you want me to put it on okay fine
i honestly don't know how pedro does it
[Music]
what's up guys i'm bobby and i'm not the
usual face here at geek culture that's
zacky but uh zaki's invited me here to
do an unboxing of sorts i think it's one
of the world's uh very few helmets that
are actually in people's hands of the
all-new mandalorian helmet that's right
so i mean i'm a huge fan of
you know star wars and of course the
mandalorian disney plus
so when they asked me to say bob you
want to come down and do this i'm like
yes i want to do this i can't wait for
this
guys
do you ever show this office by the way
in the future maybe i don't yes dude you
all seriously no joke here i'm
sidetracking a bit you all need to do a
studio tour here this place we got this
back cabinet which is like a quarter of
this office
this is like the ultimate
batcave
every toy every gaming everything i
could imagine i want in my house that i
would never be allowed to have
is here
this is cool anyway sidetrack in a
little bit let's talk about the helmet
of course when compared to the boba fett
helmet in terms of build quality
construction what's it like to wear
you know what i mean and then obviously
we got you know we got baby grogu with
us because you have to have groggy with
the helmet on i got to take the helmet
off we have to have a moment we have to
have that moment
you know the finale of season two you
know i'm talking about if you haven't
watched it yet then no spoilers but if
you've watched it you know exactly what
i'm talking about but there's no green
lightsaber do we have green lightsaber
zacky
damn it we don't have a green light see
i don't know if i can do this video all
right let's get in down to it let me
move uh
pre-vascar armor mandalorian to the side
put him back there he's okay
no mandalorians have been harmed in this
video
and let's take a look at the box here
this is uh this is quite an amazing
thing i just got to tell you this is
quite cool that we actually have there's
probably a few of these out there in the
world that are in the wild and we
actually have this box with us and
inside is this helmet i think what you
know uh what dave filoni and john fabro
done with the whole design of the
mandalorian
is phenomenal um so i'm a big fan of
what they've done and i cannot wait to
pull this helmet out anyway let's look
at the box for a moment
this is the black series so obviously
it's going to be nicer packaging than
your standard hasbro star wars stuff of
course you're going to have
mando's helmet there you're going to
have you know various different graphics
here a little bit of schematics on the
back to tell you what's there because we
got a removable tactical light in case
you want to take this into battle
but it's plastic so you're not gonna
really do well in battle but
you know we're gonna play make-believe
for a little bit then we also got
interior lights as well so if you're in
the dark in your closet you can't see a
thing and you want to put on your mando
helmet the lights will help you
put it on
this is the way all right so obviously
looking at the box here
the tape's been cut
so the geek culture team has seen this
helmet i have not
i've asked not to see because i want to
give you my true reactions to this
unboxing
on this video
as it is
i'm excited actually the box it's got
some weight to it so if you're having
this shipped to you you might have to
pay a little extra in shipping but i
think hasbro's got you covered in that
but uh feels pretty weighty on this
just say here a second
[Music]
could it be heavier than the boba fett
one
this is interesting okay
so we open this up here
okay
cardboard you know packaging
don't name you know save the environment
recycle
you probably want to keep the packaging
in case because this is a collector's
item and in case you want to trade it
one day where it's a limited piece and
you can make a few extra coin don't do
it but i'm just saying if you want to
save the packaging
all right
now the helmet is actually in white
paper but before we get into that
we've got
in various different languages most of i
can't even read
it's
safety safety sheet
you know you have to be safe as a
mandalorian
at all times
hasbro wants you safe
next we have
the instruction manual
look at that star wars the black series
the mandalorian disney hasbro 14 and
older
so parents out there if your kid's 12
they can't get the helmet
only 14 and above
abide by the rules at all times this is
the way
okay so it takes uh
one double a battery
and that's for i guess the tactical
light and for the intro lightens as well
okay you got a strap for the head so
this is adjustable
i got a small head myself personally so
i'm about to tighten this up as tight as
it goes
um
zach you got a pretty big head you're
pretty much maxed out right
about guys who have a big head right
yes
that's what i hear
that's what i hear
we won't go any further than that this
is the kids show right
i'm joking of course wait what's this
tactical light
tactical light is here whoo
interesting
so this is the best gar helmet so this
obviously is the uh
sort of the coating to this
ah nice
sort of a very kind of shiny silver like
a graphite silver texture to this
gotta say it feels high quality plastic
this feels really really nice
and
[Music]
use this uses a flashlight as well too
so if your you know lights go out at
home you can actually use this as a
flashlight well you don't drop it don't
drop it it's only a few in the world
okay
box down
the moment of truth guys
the reveal
oh
oh i'm gonna tear this up sorry guys
there goes the value of this
down oh there it is
this is it
this is badass man this is sick
i love this
wow
this is really well done the paint job
on this is spectacular
i mean of course
this is best scar right this is the top
end for mandalorian armor i mean this is
you know
from it holds off you from blasters and
lightsabers
as we saw in season two the finale you
know of course with the dark saber we're
not going to get into that of course
hey
i gotta talk about something here and
i'm joking
but this is really nice i mean it's a
plastic but it's a very
solid plastic this is a really good
composite here you can tell hasbro
actually
has done a really good job in terms of
the construction on this
this is really well made
i mean if you're into cosplay
just go for this honestly speaking i
think it's coming around 239 singapore
dollars that's probably about 100 plus
us dollars we'll put it here
zach you gotta put it here so people
know okay for our american audiences
but uh
this is really well made so you don't
have to i mean i would definitely just
go with this if you're doing a cosplay
or any sort of dress up i mean if you
want to make your own helmet and be that
person
go for it but buy this as a reference
because hasbro is going to know exactly
how this helmet looks
because they're working with disney and
star wars
so this is really nice let's look at the
inside of this for a moment here let's
look at the side of this we got a lot of
padding here which is nice i actually
like this because i tried this one on
briefly
and i wasn't getting that love from the
boba fett helmet you know i mean this is
you know 1980 star wars you know
obviously
times were tougher back then you know
we're softer we're more gentle we're
more
in tune to our emotions and our feelings
now so we need more padding in our our
mandalorian helmets
so this feels really nice here now we
gotta try on for the fit
right
as one does with a mandalorian helm
the fit
the moment of truth
[Music]
it fits
it's not bad actually
not bad i'll turn the left
or my right
look at that turn around
you can actually see out of this very
clear to be frank with you this is much
better than let's say a storm trooper
helmet or other helmets out there you
can actually see
out of this
now when i walk around the street with
this depends
but this is actually really nice it's
very comfortable around the head
actually this is really nice
damn
[Music]
like i said the straps inside actually
feel really good on this they don't feel
um like like a hard plastic that cuts
into your forehead or into the back of
your head at all it's actually really
comfortable so
take a look at this real quick i don't
know if you can get an inside shot of
that if you can look at that
so it is adjustable but it feels really
nice
i'm impressed
how do you turn the light on in this
thing
where's the tactical light we gotta put
the tactical light on right they said
they put batteries in this already so i
won't show you the battery thing you can
guess how that works
squeeze pull out there you go you got
these two levers here that this has to
fit in so you just have to push it in
squeeze and just kind of push it in like
that stay secure then you got your
tactical light there
all right
how does this turn on button inside the
helmet turns everything on have to be
smarter than the helmet
gerald come in here where's the hell
where's the button at zack you have
hasbro's number
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is the battery dead already no oh so it
goes like this
it slides in
okay so this tactical light's not
working
hmm
should we look at the instruction manual
cheryl
because that's what it's for
all right so i got this on
that looks legit
and let's just hold this button here to
turn it on
ah
this is the way
how many times are we gonna say that in
this video by the way probably a lot
this is the way this is the way this is
the way look at that tactical light baby
i can see at night
should we turn off the lights here and
see how good i look boom look at that
look at that
hey abby
abby
how do i look
you're great fantastic thank you so much
do you like the tactical light
doesn't it give it like a nice effect to
it
this is cool
see that's what i thought too it looks
very it looks realistic i gotta tell you
this is
this is wicked
this is very cool but i mean since i am
doing sort of a review here i got to
talk about some of the other aspects to
this helmet first off because of the
paint and the sheen to this
it's a fingerprint magnet
so i would highly recommend a microfiber
cloth to constantly wipe this down now
because
pedro doesn't ever take off his helmet
except when he sees
maybe grogu
[Music]
you know he doesn't get fingerprints on
it
me
i take it on and off so you're gonna get
fingerprints but for a lot of you out
there you can unbox this you're gonna
turn on the light a little bit and then
you might end up just putting it on your
shelf and
we got our vescar armor here or metal
here but this is a 3d printed not
official hasbro so hasbro you should
make this too so it matches the helmet
this is metal by the way
geek culture's got everything here in
these offices now it's time to do a
comparison between the boba fett helmet
and the mandalorian helmet which one is
better i mean you gotta have both but
you gotta choose you can only have one
which one is it these helmets do not
come with stands mind you in the box
they just come with a helmet with i wish
hasbro did include a stand with a little
bit of a plaque but it is what it is
so what they've done here which i think
is ingenious
this is not a helmet stand this is
actually
a kitchen towel holder
who would have thought
just remove the kitchen towels
then you put your helmet on the culture
thinks of everything
okay let's do a comparison side by side
obviously the boba fett helmet has much
more of a wider profile than the
mandalorian helmet and i i applaud what
star wars and disney's done with the
mandalorian design because it is a
little bit more streamlined and of
course since his best car i mean this is
the best the best armor right
um
paid a pretty penny for it by the way
you know but it's much more streamlined
so it looks really good on the head if
you have a smaller head like myself this
is going to look much better
case in point i put this on
you don't go down yet i got to talk
about you later
see how wide it is on my head now of
course you've got the visor here this
area that's much wider as well whereas
the mandos helmet is much narrower more
it's more streamlined okay
so
obviously we got the rangefinder here
which of course is
you know quintessential boba fett you
got to have that on a boba fett helmet
on the back of this you've got these
vents here that are open on the fed
helmet but on the mando helmet
they're closed
so either mando's got an uh aircon
circulation system inside of this that
we don't even know about all right now
we're gonna talk about the inside of
this real quick because yes the design
language is quite similar but you will
notice on the mando uh helmet there's a
lot more details in terms of the piping
the electronics the circuitry of course
you got the padding here which is
similar to the boba fett padding but it
does feel a little bit more comfortable
this could be of age because obviously
this is the newer helmet this is older
maybe it just from being out for quite
some time that the plastic might have
hardened a little bit but
it does feel a little bit more
comfortable but the detail inside of
this helmet is actually
quite intricate i have to say i mean
it's you know all one color it's like a
dark graphite gray
but you've got these welcome lights here
as well as i mentioned so if you're in a
dark area and you want to put the helmet
on you can see how to put the helmet on
and what way to put it on so quite a
cool little um
added benefit to it i mean
just makes it a little bit more
interesting i mean there's no heads-up
display inside of it which i thought
they would have this because all
mandalorians have a heads-up display so
there's no sort of voice synthesizer to
change your voice or to give you that
mandalorian sound
so
you've gotta
do that yourself we'll fix it in post
fantastic thank you that's what i was
waiting for jackie if you're gonna wear
this for cosplay you're gonna wear this
out for let's say a halloween night or a
costume night or you just want to wear
it out in jeans and a t-shirt
i'm not going to judge you
which one is more comfortable okay
boba fett first
okay
now it's wider here so it's a little bit
more
it'll move a little bit more here okay
now you can you can of course adjust the
straps but the plastic straps don't feel
as comfortable on the boba fett as they
do on the mando
so i feel like if i need to wear a
helmet a lot longer
the mando helmet would be the one i
would go for
now of course if you're going to be boba
fett you can be boba fett you can't
interchange otherwise
that's a sin
in the star wars land you'll be
excommunicated out from every
event out there
you can't do it
so you gotta choose but i would say that
just in terms of comparison
the mando helmet feels better on
than
oh yeah it feels much better on it's
more of a cushy feel to it so this feels
like i'm not going to get that ridge in
my forehead if i'm wearing it for a
longer period of time
also because it's a little bit narrower
and it feels a little bit smaller
this seems to be feels more you know i
haven't even tightened the straps on
this yet but it just out of the box
feels
much better yeah i would choose one i
think you got to go with the manual
helmet just in terms of comfort but
you can't just have one of these right i
mean if you're a star wars fan you gotta
have the boba fett
especially now since
he's back
if you haven't watched then well i'm
sorry you've seen it in the trailers
anyway uh but uh
yeah the manual helmet's a must-have i
think for any collector out there this
is going to look really good and by the
way let's do the kitchen towel stand
test
how does it look on the stand
balance it
there we go
there we go
there we go look at that
not bad right
that looks pretty wicked that looks
wicked
and i'm looking at it from the behind
and it already looks really good
what do you think zach you approve
yes it matches
the kitchen towel stand matches the
mandalorian helmet like a tee
yeah this is a must-have definitely must
have okay
and now the ultimate test if grogu
approves of the mandalorian helmet
it's a buy
i'm not joking this is for real
[Applause]
okay then i'll buy
i'll buy it
rogue says it's a buy
all right guys
yes yes we have links in the description
below so yes grogo they can click on
that
and they can get you too i think right
can they are you there
okay it links for grogu and the
mandalorian helmet below
sorry zacky grogue speaks you gotta
listen okay that's it for the unboxing
the manual helmet is a must-have if
you're a collector
you like it too right
you want me to put it on okay fine
so guys
that's it
i'm a fan
uh i highly recommend this when this
launches in april
[Music]
i honestly don't know how pedro does it
in the movie the show i really don't
know how he does it
you're really a difficult actor
sometimes you know that you're very
difficult got to know your lines
[Applause]
it is what it is
anyway guys
that's it for the unboxing and the first
look at the mando helmet
let us know what you think in the
comment section below is this one for
the collection are you gonna pass this
are you gonna buy it
and then of course
once you have the manual helmet you know
what you need
to rule mandalore you gotta have the
dark saber
will we get a dark saber here in good
culture zach you gotta you got a dark
saber coming yeah
sweet
all right guys that's it leave us a
comment in the comment section below
with that take care stay safe and uh
we'll see you very soon
[Applause]
bye-bye
[Music]
go with luke
go
[Music]
you